congratulations we're at the end of
lesson 4 wow that was a lot of stuff we
covered well lesson 4 is also the most
content heavy lesson in this course so
we're really happy to see you here we
cover data relationships specifically
the ancestor and the has a relationship
we also looked at queries query by kind
and then filter by ancestor and then
filter by different properties data
store indexes we took an in-depth tour
of data store indexes with allows you to
do queries in data store and we've
wrapped it up with different consistency
models and transactions in data store in
the next lesson we will look at heavy
duty stuff if you want to know what
heavy duty is or be sure to join us